yeah welcome to this video let's see
what them I usually allows the news oh
let's play an Enzo and see what line we
got Neji to eat too young this is his
book line recommendation in playing one
deform movie recently yep completed and
published d5 young let's um let's see
what what's going on here not not g3 I
think g3 or so normal okay i want to i
want to get into some kind of maybe i
can get into some kind of benoni here
and yeah not sure this was a good choice
but it looks like a pretty decent belief
or white
yeah the form y am i need to spend even
more time here Bishop g7 here maybe he's
got them be shut down f forum on Bishop
g7 and then I'm asking myself how to
protect the spawn came let's play with
bb-8 first now setting up him as a mesh
type of position there any way to
prepare this maybe I can play c4 and b5
get more use them to this kind of
position from the white side
okay why does multitude of option 1 this
is one of them yeah maybe now here on f4
I've got my GF on c4 he will probably
play a 5 not not shown okay let's
prepare b5 I hope that on f4 really
Nyjah force working out probably it does
he can't play Bishop age six now i move
i would consider definitely getting rid
of the bishop and then it's interesting
interesting maybe am he wants to play a
thorn Bishop g7 an f4 can be a can be a
problem I don't term don't have any
squares for the 994 H 39 h6 f5 something
like that and it's gone hmm jump or to
our plane yeah I probably need to do
this always also got Queen a phone I
just I just recognized this can be a big
problem okay but first I need to I need
to cover it looks a bit strange
Wow yeah this can be a big big problem
on this diagonal age 6 Bishop h6 ssome
trick
I hope I see this yeah this is really
working this kind of trick Queen dat I
just go here Bishop g7 I play night sir
Knight to c3 yeah yeah okay empty six
but I'm okay well then they exchange
even yeah it simply wasn't a good
position I got into a really bad bad
form of a benoni and also I'm a position
type that he knows very well he placed
as Emma sure all the time it hazard
recommended in the book also yeah there
are ways to get into a benoni structure
in this industry and I think even pretty
good ways but um I didn't didn't play
one of the good ways just just bad yeah
you could think of resigning but I've
played I've played him a couple of times
already and sometimes he he really
butchers up in time scrambles so let's
um play couple of more moves
it's a it's very bad though of course
gap you down on time but nevertheless
yeah the faint hope is that somehow i
get to the b2 pond but it's really just
just hope there's no one real reason to
think it might happen on top tonight
deform maybe be four ninety-five not
sure that this was so all the best year
before a 95 would help me a lot if I got
this in time time yeah let's so let's go
for this so here and I'm also
threatening a form and 93
rookie 7 SB should be five so i like it
i get me to at the end so and so yeah
like to just have no very lucky okay i
could resign I know but I'm warning ya
know now I to resign yeah it was simply
a very bad position on the opening some
bad benoni with some maybe some temple
down and and it's not structure i like
very much anyway yeah this especially
was was annoying and therefore of course
was even stronger i mean this was wasn't
bad but f-for just blows me off the
board as I didn't have any move and
anyway so it didn't really matter so
much the zone yeah this was also met if
simply the bet a bad position so this
transformation into benoni is not
advisable it seems from from this
specific move water yeah thanks for
watching this